I don't have my phone with me.
Huh?
Okay.
You sure?
100%?
Okay.
Tomorrow inshallah Salat al-Fajr will be
at 5:00.
Tomorrow morning will be at 5:00
[Arabic recitation]
5:00.
Hm?
[Silence]
So yesterday I promised a story
with respect to
these first
opening
points here that we began
yesterday morning.
And that is
an-najasat listing the various types of
najasa, the various types of filth. Now
again, as a reminder,
when we say filth,
this is not just a general linguistic
term, this is a very specific
legislative term.
Rules,
halal haram is built on what we define
with this term.
So filth
is not just something that we consider
to be
impure or un-
unclean. Filth is also not just
something that we consider to be
immoral. It is
whoa hook moon shar'i. It is actually
a
a legislative
that has very specific parameters. And
for our intents and purposes,
when I say the word filth, we're talking
about an-najasat.
Right? When I say something is unclean,
that is something which could be filth,
could be other things which are
unsightly, un-
you know, un- un-
unsightly, gross, etc.
So the first two things on this list, of
course, at the top of the list
is
The first two things on the top of this
list with respect to filth,
those things which are najis,
are
the human being's urine or feces. Those
two things are considered to be filthy
inherently. Inherently filthy.
Right? When we say inherently meaning
they could never be cleaned. And it's
not an issue of how potent or lack
thereof they are or
it doesn't matter if they have a smell,
if they don't have a smell, doesn't
matter what the person's diet is,
doesn't matter as long as it has come
out of those two paths and is
categorized as being either urine, which
comes from the bladder, or feces, which
comes from the colon, from the
intestines, then it is considered to be
filthy.
Everybody knows this. Right?
This is one of the first things we learn
as Muslimin. When we say being clean, we
learn these two things. So you may say,
"Well, why are we
taking so much time to discuss these two
things?"
There's a big difference between knowing
something and
having heard something
but not knowing its evidence. the
whole point of this
process here is learning
the evidence,
meaning from the Quran and Sunnah,
ad-dalil.
And this is the difference between a
scholar
and a muqallid. Right?
And this is a very
interesting point. So
a few of my mashayikh in Yemen,
they lived in an area that was very very
dense with
the Houthis. We've all heard of
the Houthis now because of the news
and the wars and so forth. But these are
a type of Shiism that roughly they they
would follow the the 12 Imam or the
Ja'fari madhhab of Shiism. It's a very
extreme strain of Shiism, right?
And they have their own scholars and
they have their own
workings and so forth.
And
they used to hold these debates,
right? Between their
shuyukh and the shuyukh of the Ahlus
Sunnah, and they would gather and
you could probably see some of these
debates in in in other countries
being filmed now, but this was
you know, in the late '90s before
these, you know, cameras were so
ubiquitous.
And so
they were constantly warning people not
to go to study with these with these
nawasib. They call Ahlus Sunnah
nawasib. Nawasib meaning people that
curse the Prophet's family, sallallahu
alayhi wa sallam. This is kind of like
propaganda, right?
And so
they came and they said, "Look, we have
one question." This was the debate. "We
have one question.
If you answer this question,
we will not teach anymore here in this
area.
But if you can't answer this question,
you have to come to
these
to our humble masjid in our humble
school, and you have to
be there with the general
lectures that are held."
So they said, "Okay, you're on."
Said, "One question.
What is the evidence
from the Quran and Sunnah
or Sunnah
that feces, human feces,
is filthy?"
Right?
And they started to wring their hands.
"Everybody knows this. We already know
this. Everyone knows this." And I take
their hat off and rub in their head. And
there were many of them, right?
And they could not produce an evidence
from the Quran or Sunnah
that feces is filthy. Now we all know
this, right? But
this seems something that the
evidence would be readily available, and
it is to those who have studied, but
this is the difference between
knowing the inner workings of something
and knowing that something works.
And so one of the evidences that they
used
is
the narration
of
Mu'adh ibn Jabal that the Prophet,
sallallahu alayhi wa sallam, was
praying.
And
when he was praying,
the companions were praying behind him,
and suddenly,
while he was in salah, he took his shoes
off and put them on his left.
He just took them off in salah and put
them to his left.
And so the companions,
they just saw that the Prophet,
sallallahu alayhi wa sallam, took his
shoes off and put them to his left. So
they all took their shoes off in salah,
put their shoes
you know,
to the side, many of them between their
feet.
And so
when he finished salah, he turned to
them and said, "Why did you take your
shoes off?"
They said, "We saw you take your shoes
off, so we took ours off."
He said, "Jibril came to me and informed
me that there was a athara
in my in the sole of one of my shoes.
Athara meaning
piece of feces that was stuck to the
bottom of the sole
of one of his shoes. And so he took his
[Arabic recitation]
to shed that najasa during his salah.
And so
you know, to their credit, they did
follow through, and many of those
brothers that were in that gathering
actually later left Shiism and started
to come and study there with Ali Sunnah
and they became very beneficial to their
respective tribes.
[Silence]
This narration is in Sunan Abi Dawud.
The Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam
tells us
in the narration of Abi Hurairah, if any
of you happens to step into either.
Either here in this context means
feces or urine, either one.
Because
either
when it is in the context, either
usually means something that is harmful
or something that is an annoyance.
And they refer to an annoyance
as that which is
feces or urine that would be in the in
the street or, you know, a passerby
would be harmed by it, would be annoyed
by it, it's a nuisance. So, they refer
to it as an either, right? Instead of
using the word feces, instead of using
the word urine,
you can noon for either,
either, right?
So, he says if any of you happens to
step on an either,
then a turab,
the dirt, the sand
is considered to be an adequate scrubber
for the bottoms of the soles of his
shoes.
He says,
and the
what we are to understand of this is
that this wouldn't be appropriate for
the clothing, for instance. You wouldn't
just take sand and rub it on the
clothing to remove it from your your
clothing. That would need water.
But each
each it is the it is the same thing
on your shoes, on your clothing, on your
body, on your place of salah, it may be
the same type of najasa, but each has
its own way of being cleaned
because is it it is an issue of
it is an issue of
you know, it is it is very
what's the word I'm looking for?
It is something that is
to the
to the what is appropriate for that
actual a thing. So, it is appropriate
for the soles of the shoes, being that
water cannot penetrate them, being that
the binding to the soles of these shoes
is very weak, and being that this is
something that just normally walking and
and wearing the shoes will eventually
make this go away,
it becomes appropriate. The word I'm
looking for is relative. So, it is
relative to the shoes
that this is how they are cleaned, to
the clothing that water is used, to the
place of salah, right? That just a
bucket of water, for instance, without
scrubbing. We will get to how to clean a
najasat in the following chapter,
[Arabic recitation]
But this is an evidence that
feces is a type of najasa.
[Silence]
And as for the evidence for urine, that
urine is a type of najasa,
the narration of Anas, and Arabi and
Bella film masjid.
[Silence]
And as for urine being a type of najasa,
the evidence is in the narration of
Anas, the well-known narration of Anas,
that
a
nomad, a Arabi, someone who lives in the
desert,
had urinated in
a part of the masjid.
And so, the Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi
Wasallam, when some of the companions
got up to,
you know, deal with him,
the the Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi
Wasallam said,
leave him be, let him finish, right?
And so, when he had concluded,
he
told the companions to bring a bucket
of water and to pour that water onto
the puddle of urine, hence diluting it,
hence and so that's a different way that
it is cleaned when it's on the ground.
We see the difference, but it is still a
najasa, right? But it is relative. A
najasa that is on the soles of your
shoes is different and has different
parameters than one that is on your
clothing, than one that is on your body,
that one that is on your
on the place of salah, even on different
parts of your body, it is different,
right? It being in the place of
najasa, where it commonly is, is very
different than being on your hand, than
being very different than being on a
person's face. So, it is relative to
where it is.
It is either more strict or less strict
based on the place that it is, and we
will get into that in the next chapter,
[Arabic recitation]